hey
i'm gavin goulden an art director at
insomniac games
and this is each and every suit of
marvel spider-man
and marvel spider-man miles morales
we're covering the visual design of
about 60 suits
so let's get to it first up let's talk
about all the suits
seen in marvel's spider-man miles
morales
the animated suit the goal for the
animated suit
was to create something that everybody
who watched saturday morning cartoons
would be familiar with using simplified
geometry
and a sub shader we think we really
nailed something of nostalgia value
a cell shader is a custom material that
we'd use in game
to crush down colors and create an
outline that really mimics hand-drawn
classical 2d animation into the
spider-purse suit
everyone at insomniac really wanted to
tip our hats to the creators of the film
into the spider verse to do so we
created the suit with custom proportions
as well as a complex network of shaders
similar to what you'd see in the movie
this means that we created shaders that
help show
print details and chromatic aberration
in game birth cards
the onomatopoeia speech balloons that
you see when you're fighting enemies
as well as the on twos animation vibe
the verse
which is custom code we use to drop
frames to mimic the same animation style
in into the spider verse the advanced
tech suit
the advanced tech suit is an armored
suit that miles morales wears
that uses sleek armor plating all
throughout the costume
fans would recognize the red chevron and
general color blocking throughout the
outfit
as it's similar to the classic outfit
from the comics
the bodega catsuit this is truly an
organic
collaborative experience from insomniac
games and everybody's favorite suit at
the studio
essentially our designers wanted to
create an authentic experience
to someone living in new york so having
a cat in a bodega
only seemed fitting having to rescue the
cat for the bodega
owner we named it spiderman why not
create a custom suit
that always has the cat in the backpack
fighting enemies along with you
the brooklyn visions academy suit we
wanted to pay respect to miles's
background as a student at brooklyn
visions academy
so we created a custom blazer with the
insignia of his school to go over the
iconic suit
this is also a great opportunity to show
in-game cloth dynamics
during gameplay and cinematics classic
suit
this is the defining look of spider-man
it's important to pay respect to the
past and where the character came from
from his comic book origins
but also have an eye to the future and
put it through our insomniac lens
much like peter parker's advanced suit
in the original marvel spiderman putting
it through the lens means
giving more realistic materials to the
suit and adding construction details
to help sell how spiderman could
actually make
the outfit beyond that the classic suit
is key
to mile's narrative it shows that he's
stepping out from the shadow of his
mentor peter parker with his own defined
look
in black and red the crimson cowl suit
this is one of our very first custom
suits that we designed along with artist
john stout we wanted this to feel agile
and
stealthy at the same time we referenced
boxing gear and training athletic
outfits that one might wear in the real
world and then put
our own spin through using new materials
like
nylons and rubbers and leathers to
better fit
and protect spiderman the great
responsibility suit
this it was important to show the
relationship between peter
and miles peter's acting as miles's
mentor
and gives him a hand-me-down suit the
narrative reason
for using this suit is to show that
miles is uncomfortable with becoming
spider-man he's essentially wearing
peter's outfit and becoming
peter parker not just becoming his own
spider-man it's ill-fitting
and has noticeable construction details
like exposed zippers
and seams that give it a lower quality
feel to
what you might see in the advanced suit
on peter parker
the homemade suit this was taken
directly from the comics
and made to look like something thrown
together from the clothing that miles
may have
lying around at his house using our
advanced material
shaders we're able to show layered
detail such as tiled
fabric weaving and peeling throughout
all of the fabrics
miles morales 2020 suit the team
took what was originally a variant cover
and made an in-game
suit by referencing futuristic designs
of helmets
and biker jackets we created custom
emblems for the
jacket backing as well as complex
shaders for
the 2020 helmet to have animated led
expressions to help really sell the
vision of what the variant cover
originally showed fans miles morales
2099 suit
this was originally a variant cover
designed by lee garbett we were honored
to take this to completion
in 3d what's really great about this
suit is that we also have an homage to
the original 2099
spider-man miguel o'hara seen on his
chest
emblem throughout the suit purple rain
suit
we collaborated with marvel games to
create this totally unique suit to help
tie the relationship of aaron davis
miles uncle
to miles morales this has similar design
principles seen in the prowler outfit we
use the same color scheme
and give it a sleek armored look this
also pays homage
to the ultimate prowler design created
by sarah pacilli
by having gray inserts on the side
of the suit the programmable matter suit
the programmable matter suit is using
technology designed by
miles morales's childhood friend finn
mason but repurposed to better fit
spiderman and his color scheme it uses
the chrome-like appearance you may see
in the underground's weapons and
technology
but also has the red spider emblem that
fans would recognize
as miles morales despite spider training
suit
this suit is designed to tie directly
into where you may have seen miles
morales where we left off
the marvel spider-man as a new protege
to peter parker
this suit is purposely designed to use
street clothes
that miles morales may have just laying
around in his closet this ties the
civilian miles morales to his very
beginning stages as spider-man
before truly taking on the mantle
the sports wear suit the sportswear suit
is intended to be a step beyond the
spider training suit
it uses piecemeal items from spiderman
suit given to him by peter parker but
also
incorporates winterwear this is also an
important
suit narratively to show that miles is
staying with his training as spider-man
going from the very initial suit to this
new and improved
training suit and then eventually into
the great responsibility suit
as a true spider-man the strike suit
this is designed by artist dave raposa
we really wanted to have a suit that
focused on the venom energy
that is natural to miles morales as
spider-man and also speak to the
youthfulness
of the hero himself this suit is created
by
using plates of armored rubber and
insulation
as well as energy coursing throughout
the suit itself
in spider emblems that trail along the
arms
and through the chest and back the
tracksuit
this is a custom suit designed with
famed miles morales artist javier garon
we really wanted to have a suit that
focused on the athleticism
of miles morales and the youthfulness of
the hero
we referenced parkour gear and free
running outfits
to help influence the suit as well as
athletic gear to help make him
appear sleek and agile the end suit
this is a suit from a futuristic setting
and an older miles morales
using materials like padded leathers
denims and nylons
really helps ground the suit inside of
our realistic world
uptown pride suit miles shows his love
for his new community by leading quest
throughout all of harlem
in return he's gifted a new suit that
closely resembles his iconic outfit
but with gold trim seen throughout the
winter suit
this suit shows miles connection to his
new community in harlem
specifically his connection to hailey
who gifts
miles her earmuffs and scarf to go over
his suit
in the cold new york winter hello again
up next we'll be talking about all the
suits peter parker wears
and marvel spiderman
the classic suit we wanted the very
first suit you see when playing the game
to be iconic that anyone on the planet
could look at and immediately know what
it is
appropriately we used the suit designed
by steve ditko
one of the creators of spider-man we
gave this suit a more realistic
rendering style
by mixing real world materials like
spandex and rubber
on the spandex you'll have banded
highlights using anisotropic shading
on rubber you'll have more matte
highlights to help give some contrast
and materials seen throughout the suit
the amazing suit inspired by the films
this suit uses more tactile materials
to help give more mobility to spider-man
it also uses more real world items that
spider-man could easily have access to
such as
visors seen in the mask and soles on the
bottom of the feet
to help really ground it inside of our
world
antioch suit in the final fight
of marvel spider-man we wanted to show
that even when he's down and out
peter parker can out-think his opponent
dr octopus his former mentor
otto octavius pete uses the same
technology
doc uses in his tentacles to create a
new suit to help protect him from his
enemies attacks
the arachnid rider suit designed by dave
raposa we wanted to draw inspiration
from the kind of japanese cartoons we
may have all watched as kids
we wanted to make sure that this clearly
reads his spidey so while we did have
horns and armor plating breaking the
silhouette we used a color scheme
that most fans would be very familiar
with while also giving
a new futuristic look to the hero
the advanced suit insomniac had the
great honor of creating
a totally new suit for spider-man we
wanted to create something that was very
iconic and stood out
as our very own hero to do that we
created a white spider
that is seen throughout the torso on the
chest and on the back
not only does this stand out it also
helps protect
spider-man beyond that we also use
panels
throughout the suit to help give padding
on pete while he's swinging throughout
new york
and fighting enemies armored advanced
suit it used the same design language as
seen in the advanced suit
incorporating protective white armor
giving it a very
stark finish that helps to stand out
bombastic bagman's suit a more modern
take on the longer suit from the
fantastic four
originally this suit is fairly
ill-fitting as it's just a hand-me-down
from the human torch
we wanted to take this suit and give it
a more modern
look by using materials you may find in
the real world like nylon and rubber
we also wanted to incorporate the gloves
and the boots
into the suit more with nylon inserts on
the side
to better fit pete and not be as baggy
like you may see in the comments
aaron aikman armor a futuristic armor
that uses the same landmarks seen in a
classic spider-man suit
sleek cybernetic panels layered over top
of padded
latex cyborg spider-man suit
as a child of the 80s and the 90s it was
a great chance
to pay respect to the comics that i read
as a kid
using segmented metal panels we wanted
to give a nod to death lock
while also using advanced cybernetics
and augmentations throughout the arm to
better fit our universe
like an anatomical rubber structure
under the armor
and wires seen throughout the dark suit
this suit is given to you by black cat
in her storyline
we wanted to use materials similar to
what you may find in her costume
throughout the game this is our take on
a suit scene
in the deadpool comic run electrically
insulated suit
with this suit we wanted to show that
spider is wearing something more bulky
and layered to help protect him from
electric shocks we did this by
referencing real world protective
materials
like heavy padding and rubbers
the fear itself suit inspired by the
armor scene in the comics we wanted to
reference the more fantastical
asgardian armor by creating metal scales
throughout the suit
as well as showing the powerful
technology surging through him
with white energy the future foundation
suit
to help welcome the fantastic four back
home we wanted to put
the fantastic four spidey suit through
the insomniac lens
while the overall design stays the same
from what fans may be familiar with in
the comics
we did add construction details
throughout the suit and
hardened plastic panels to help give
material breakup and visual interest
iron spider armor taking inspiration
from the civil war comic series
this suit is typically red fabric with
gold plating over top
we wanted to put this through the
insomniac lens we created
more gold inlays and the highly detailed
gold
plating throughout the suit as well as
more construction details to help
show how the suit is created and
explained the flexibility pete may have
while in the outfit the added
segmentation
in the larger armor panels helps show
how the armor plates
may slide over top of each other while
pete is swimming
iron spider suit inspired by marvel
studios avengers
infinity war inspired by the films we
wanted to capture the same
car paint type look seen in the movies
we did this by creating a colored
specular material
and thinner armor panels that slide
across the outfit
when we create our materials in game
there are two different properties
there's gloss and there's spec gloss is
the tightness
of a highlight so it could be pinpoint
or it could be very broad
then specular is the level of
reflectivity that a material may have
as well as the color that it may reflect
off
into the spider birth suit we really
wanted to make this feel
like the peter parker from into the
spider verse with exaggerated
proportions like an elongated skull in
arms
we also had a new approach to shaders to
create something very custom
to help mimic the same look you may see
in the films this introduced
hatching halftone and fresnel
specifically for this suit
fresnel is the amount of reflectance you
see at glancing angles
the last dance suit based largely on
real world reference
we wanted to create a wardrobe that a
biker version of spidey may wear
like a red leather jacket with blue
inserts that mimic
the classic spidey outfit we also use
real world materials such as heavy
leathers and denim
to really give it a believable biker
feel
spider armor mark 1 suit
this is the very first bulletproof
spidey suit that he creates
the armor is intended to be bulkier and
a prototype of other seats we may see
later on but still
using the classic web pattern scene and
spiderman suits
the highly reflective chrome helps pick
up all of our ray traced reflections
this means that on all of the armored
panels throughout the suit
you can see the world around peter
parker
spider armor mark ii suit a sleeker
version of the bulletproof suit
this uses a chainmail-like material with
layers of ballistic nylon
and rubber over top for extra protection
we also add
inserts and construction seams for more
flexibility
spider armor mark iii suit taken from
the amazing spider-man comics of the
late 90s
we wanted to upgrade this suit in our
realistic setting to do so
we added more details on the specularity
throughout the metal plating in the suit
and also added more details to the
plates themselves to help justify
their points of articulation and how
they may slide over each other
during combat and traversal
spider armor mark iv suit this armored
suit is very sleek
and intended to capture the same
rendering style seen in the artwork
by famed artist alex ross we incorporate
patterns into the specular detail
to help give it a more iridescent
feeling and a higher
tech quality such as finer scales
negative suit spider-man gets this suit
by entering the negative zone of martin
lee otherwise known
as mr negative the suit is designed to
appear like a photo negative
by creating custom textures in a shader
that has
blue white energy coursing throughout
the entire outfit
the noir suit drawing inspiration from
the comics we want to reference
real world materials that may help make
the suit more believable
to do so we looked at pilot gear from
the turn of the century
we used heavier wools leather and
detailing throughout the cap to really
help make it feel like pilot goggles
and a flight helmet resilient suit
designed by famed amazing spiderman
artist gabrielle delatto
we wanted to create a suit that was very
sleek but also armored to help protect
spiderman we also used aggressive lines
throughout the suit's design
to help reflect the same type of
rendering style seen in gabriel's comic
book art
secret war suit like most black suits in
our game
it's really important that they read
well in all lighting conditions
to do so we create material contrast to
help pick up
specular highlights on this suit we used
a high gloss blue emblem on the torso
the inverted red piping seen on the mask
and then a higher
gloss seen throughout the outfit to help
break up the fabric details
the scarlet spider suit this is my
personal favorite spidey suit
by taking a design from the 1990s we
were able to really modernize it in
marvel spider-man we added protective
rubber panels
and high-tech fabric seen throughout the
suit we brought in homemade elements
that you may see from the comics
such as the hoodie and stenciled
spider-man emblems then also referenced
military industrial gear for his bracers
scarlet spider ii suit similar to the
original scarlet spider outfit
we used construction seams to help break
up the suit
this also adds visual interest and
construction details to help inform
how the suit may work realistically this
suit also uses material contrast to help
inform
the function of the suit the black areas
on the upper body are more protective
while the red suit is lighter and more
flexible
spider plants too we wanted to capture
the mangaverse spidey look by using
exaggerated proportions
like a slightly larger head and
expressive eyes we also created
a complex custom shader just for the
suit by our technical artist
jay twasseum this suit has a thin
terminator but also
a fresnel and faked light direction to
really help make it pop
off screen and mimic the same look you
may see in print
media our outline rather than using
black ink
adopts the color of the suit underneath
to help make it feel softer
and more natural spider punk suit
we really wanted to capture the
do-it-yourself mentality seen in the
punk scene
we wanted to really show that this suit
was made with lower technology
and is handmade we also added worn denim
and pins to help show the personality of
the suits wear
spider uk suit the most iconic thing
about this suit
is the union jack seen throughout the
torso and the asymmetrical technology
seen on peter parker's wrist
spirit spider suit really dipping our
toe into horror on this
one we wanted the suit to seem like it
was skin
stretched over muscles and bone to do
this we used thinner wrinkles
to help really show the crinkling of
skin as muscles flex and deform
the stark suit drawing inspiration from
marvel studios
captain america civil war we really
wanted to have the same look in our suit
as seen in the films to do so we created
tiling
normal fabric details that really help
make the suit feel crisp
as well as using material contrast the
protective
rubber inserts throughout the outfit the
stealth
big time suit during production this was
actually our very first
variant suit that we used to help prove
out our systems
we purposely wanted to pick something
that was a stark contrast
from our advanced suit rather than blue
red and white we chose
black and green we also used real world
references
like protective rubber and nylon to help
make the suit feel
sleek but also functional in addition we
also had
green led strips throughout the suit to
help make it really stand out
in different lighting conditions stealth
suit
mcu in addition to inspiration found
in spider-man far from home we also used
real world reference
like motorcycle gear tactical equipment
and leathers
this really helped inform our material
reads and contrasts for more flexible
elements of the suit
to something that is more protective for
spidey
upgraded suit inspired by spider-man
far from home we wanted to show the
upgraded tech found in the suit
by mimicking the more elaborate
threading seen throughout the suit as
well as
the higher gloss protective elements
webbed suit we always wanted to give
this suit out
to the community as a free gift we
really do the film
justice as well as capturing the
material contrasting throughout the suit
and really nailing the raised webbing
look that is unique to this outfit
to do so we created each web in
geometric detail
manually muddled out and layered over
top of the suit to give realistic
shading and specular highlights
wrestler suit as a lifelong fan of both
spider-man
and professional wrestling this seemed
like a perfect match for me
we took inspiration from the ultimate
spider-man series
this suit uses sweats and a custom
personalized spider emblem on the chest
we also added a lucha mask velocity suit
we had the honor of working with adi
gronov famed marvel artist
and costume designer to create this
aerodynamic
armor-plated custom suit while the suit
helps increase speed we also wanted to
show the energy coursing throughout the
suit
and giving more aggressive lines to the
armor panels making the suit feel as
though it was sharp
and cutting through the air as
spider-man swings through new york city
vintage comic book suit everyone at
insomniac loves this suit
we've really wanted to capture the
feeling of old school comics and
cartoons
in a 3d world it's truly the brainchild
of our technical artist
jay tuwassen they created a custom
shader to nail the hand-drawn
spider-man appearance by introducing
hatching
gradient shading and fresnel to really
nail that ink drawn look
we use reverse tone mapping to help make
the suit pop off screen
in all lighting conditions spiderman
2099 black suit
we wanted the original 2099 suit to feel
higher tech than what you may have seen
in the comics our suit uses bulletproof
plastics that are cleaner and higher
polished
mixed with a more protective layer of
nylon and rubber
spiderman 2099 white suit
the white 2099 suit is fully armored and
uses intricate panels
that mimic human anatomy to embellish on
the comic design further we added
segmentation to the armor panels
as well as faceting to the spider
emblems to help pick up
more specular highlights for visual
interest fastening is a change in planes
throughout a model's surface
so rather than having a clean specular
highlight
it'll be broken up to give it more depth
and detail
the homemade suit taking inspiration
from spidey's very
first appearance in the mcu we wanted to
capture the same homemade feel
as seen in marvel studios captain
america civil war
by using sweats and older hoodies that
pete may have access to
finally undies this originally started
as a gag
for when pete comes out of a
hallucination caused by
scorpion's poison our designers found
that we needed a reward after the
mission
and it was a great opportunity to add
some humor to an intense emotional
battle
and that's it that's the visual design
of every suit from marvel spider-man
and marvel spider-man miles marvelous i
hope you learned something
and thanks for watching
[Music]
you